Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere kosmische Angelegenheiten. Ja mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und äh
Hier gibt's eine weitere Ausgabe in der Reihe der Gespräche, die ich auf den Kanarischen Inseln führe. Das ist jetzt auch die letzte, geplante und äh heute geht's äh auch ein wenig wieder um Teles
aber mal mit einem ganz anderen Spin,
wollen wir über das Currenko Teleskop-Araye sprechen und dafür äh begrüße ich erstmal meinen Gesprächspartner, nämlich Daniel Marzin. Hallo.
Tja.
Herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit.
Ja hallo äh willkommen auf La Palma.
Ja, danke, genau. Wir sind auf La Palma konkret äh sitzen wir hier gerade im äh Instituto der Astrophysico,
La Palma, also es gehört zum IRC, ne? Es ist sozusagen die Niederlassung ähm hier auf La Palma.
Und ja, hier hast du deinen äh Büro, aber da bist du nicht immer. Du du bist hier, wenn du äh wenn du mal hier bist, da kommen wir gleich drauf. Äh,
drauf zu sprechen, aber deine Rolle ähm
ist hier die Leitung dieses Projekts des ähm sogenannten LST Projekts, das large Teleskop, das wieder so ein schöner Name, ne, wer Teleskoplarge-Sizze, Teleskop. Man will nicht so genau werden manchmal
habe ich immer so den Eindruck, wenn's um Teleskope geht und das Ganze ist eben Teil eines größeren äh Projektes, nämlich des äh Currenko.
Teleskop-Aray CTA.
Ja vielleicht mal kurz zur Aussprache.
Ähm ist eigentlich ein äh ist ein Name von einem Wissenschaftler. Es war ein russischer Wissenschaftler und Aussprache ist Sheran Koff.
Und äh hat dafür einen Nobelpreis bekommen, dass er diese diese Strahlung mal mal entdeckt hat.
Dafür können wir den Namen auf jeden Fall richtig aussprechen.
Genau und ich heiße Daniel Malin. Ich komme ursprünglich auch aus Russland zufällig. Äh viele Pavel Scherenkov. Ich hatte es mittlerweile tot. Ich äh ich lebe noch.
Und ich bin dann denkt dran, ab äh neunziger Jahre, Anfang der neunziger Jahre nach nach Deutschland gekommen und seitdem bin ich irgendwie ähm Deutschland, Spanien, Japan.
Genau, ja, erzähl doch mal, wie wie du äh zur Wissenschaft gekommen bist und äh was was so dein äh Weg gewesen ist.
Ja wahrscheinlich wie wie viele junge Leute habe ich mich für Ursprung des Universums äh interessiert für,
für so grundsätzliche Sachen warum sind wir hier? Wo kommen wir her? Wo gehen wir hin?
Da war Physik klingt was äh irgendwas Spannendes.
Doch am Anfang wollte ich auch äh die Geschichte der Naturwissenschaften studieren. Das kann man in Deutschland nicht so äh viel machen oder in äh es gibt nur sehr wenige Stelle, wo Stellen, wo man es machen kann.
Und da wurde der Weg über ein Grundstudium in in Physik an der Universität Hamburg.
Und das hat mir dann doch sehr gefallen, dann bin ich dann doch bei Physik geblieben. Und dann ähm bereits meine Diplomarbeit äh.
In der Experimentalphysikgruppe ähm mit den gemacht damals hießen die Hekra,
die waren bereits auf auf La Palma hier stationiert. Bin ich vor 20 Jahren das erste Mal nach La Palma gekommen, um Daten in so einem Charikoff Teleskop zu nehmen und äh seitdem bin ich bin ich dabei.
Also mit anderen Worten, du bist gleich in das Thema, was dich dein Leben lang äh dein wissenschaftliches Leben lang begleiten sollte, zumindest bis hierhin und es dauert glaube ich noch eine Weile äh gleich reingestolpert. Das hört man ja oft, dass so
eher zufällig man irgendwas ähm auswählt und dann bleibt man dabei selten, dass mal wirklich jemand komplett den Bereich wechselt. Das äh scheint so eine wiederkehrende Geschichte zu sein.
Ähm jetzt hast du aber eine Professur in Tokio.
Ja ich bin zur Zeit ähm project der Social Professor. Äh heißt es so schön an der Universität Tokio. An sich ist es eine Wissenschaftsstelle, die keine Lehre hat. Deswegen heißt es Projekt.
Mhm, also eine reine Forschungsprofession.
Forschungsprofessur und da geht's um äh um diese um die.
Teleskope von von wird aus äh drei unterschiedlichen Teleskoptypen bestehen,
Die Grundidee ist ähm zwei ähm von äh Teleskopen zu bauen, um den ganzen Himmel abzugrasen,
von Süd äh und von unterschiedliche Quellen sieht einfach durch die Dynamik sich dreht,
von einem Platz nicht das Ganze Universum sehen. Also es gibt sehr spannende Objekte, äh die man vom vom Norden aus sehen kann, die man aber von Süden nicht sehen kann und andersrum auch,
Deswegen gibt es dann ähm zwei Orte die wir uns ausgesucht haben einmal im Norden hier auf La Palma.
Und äh einmal in Chile, Paranal.
ESO-Gelände sein, wo äh wo das zweite ähm der zweite Standpunkt von von CTA sein wird. Da gibt es in äh halt wie ich schon sagte drei Teleskoptypen,
ich bin der Projektmanager von von sogenannten.
Deswegen der Name.
Deswegen der Name äh und da ist die Idee äh an die kleinen Energien äh zu kommen,
und äh es gibt dann Midsize Teleskope, die sind dann ähm über mehr Teleskope, sind aber kleiner und es gibt auch smalls heißt Teleskop,
Die sind dann klein, aber es gibt dann viele von denen. Und hier auf La Palma äh werden nur zwei äh von diesen drei Typen gebaut,
nur die large, sei es Teleskop und die Miets heißt Teleskope und im Süden werden wir alle drei.
Haben und hatte ein bisschen mit der Physik zu tun, die wir vom Norden äh machen können und die wir vom Süden machen können. Hat aber auch was mit der Finanzierung zu tun.
Gut, bevor wir auf dieses äh Projekt noch mal genauer zu sprechen kommen, müssen wir glaube ich erstmal äh ein wenig einführen und äh herleiten.
Warum das Ganze jetzt eigentlich überhaupt stattfinden soll? Warum will man jetzt äh mit diesen Teleskopen den Himmel abgrasen
und äh was ist sozusagen das, was man eigentlich finden möchte? Ähm das Ganze hängt mit kosmischer Strahlung zusammen.
Kannst du mal erläutern, was an der kosmischen Strahlung da an der Stelle so besonders äh ist und äh welche Effekte hier eine Rolle spielen,
und was es mit der Cherrykoff-Strahlung konkret auf sich hat.
Die kosmische Strahlung ist ja ganz faszinierend, wurde von mehr als 100 Jahren entdeckt von Viktor Hess,
mit Ballonexperimenten, das gab's auch Nobelpreis dafür,
Strahlung, die aus dem Kosmos kommt und kennen wir auch Bayern wir,
ein Flugzeug fliegen, sollte man nicht so oft fliegen, nicht so hoch, weil natürlich man da eher diese ionisierenden Strahlung ausgesetzt ist, was äh nicht unbedingt sehr sehr gesund ist. Die Frage ist.
Wo kommen die her? Was sind die Quellen von dieser kosmischen Strahlung? Das ist ein sehr hohen Energien. Äh wie äh kommt das Universum dazu, Teilchen zu so hohen äh Energien zu beschleunigen? Wie macht man das?
Hier auf der Erde kriegen wir es nicht hin,
Auch wenn wir sehr viel Geld investieren und versuchen ähm Teilchen aufeinander knallen zu lassen, auch die Energien, die kosmische Strahlung äh hergibt, kommen wir nicht hin.
Wie muss man sich wie rum muss man sich diese Energien vorstellen? Ist das so das, was so am CERN äh erzeugt wird oder.
Strahlung geht zu Energien hoch 221 Elektronenvolt da sind so richtige äh Tennisbälle und und mehr äh.
Die äh in einem äh in einem Proton äh in einem Proton steck.
Also es ist schon sehr, sehr gewaltig. Wir sind natürlich sehr selten äh bei bei kleineren Energien sind's dann mehr,
aber es gibt irgendwelche Objekte, die zu so gewaltigen Energien pro elementare Teilchen kommen. Ähm jetzt ist das Problem mit der,
Strahlung, dass sie vor allem aus den geladenen Teilchen äh besteht und geladene Teilchen. Ich ich rede jetzt von der elektrischen Ladung,
Pferden, durch äh Magnetfelder abgelenkt.
Wir haben Magnetfelder außerhalb von unserer Galaxie in unsere Galaxie und auch in unserem ähm Soundsystem.
Und so kommt es, dass äh die kosmische Strahlung relativ isotropiert.
Also gleich verteilt.
Gleich verteilt ist, dass wir die aus der Richtungsinformation äh sehr wenig ableiten können.
Woher eigentlich diese äh hochenergetischen geladenen Teilchen kommen.
Und da wollen wir durch die Gamerstrahlung uns behelfen.
Strahlung ist auch ein Teil der der kosmischen Strahlung besteht aber aus aus Kammerstrahlung Kammerstrahlung ist ein Teil von elektromagnetischem Spektrum das elektrische magnetisch das elektromagnetische Spektrum kennt man ja.
Geht von äh Radiowellen bis äh über ähm Infrarote Strahlung, äh optischer Strahlung.
Ultraviolett ähm äh Röntgenstrahlung dann in die in die Gammerstrahlung rüber.
Und äh unser Verständnis ist, dass die ähm Produktion der German Strahl sehr wohl mit der Produktion von der kosmischen Strahlung in Verbindung steht,
Das heißt, die Hoffnung ist, wenn wir eine Gammestrahlungsquellen finden, dann wären's wahrscheinlich auch dieselben Quellen sein, die die kosmische Strahlung.
Äh hervorrufen. Ist aber auch nicht äh eindeutig.
Weil ähm um die äh Gammerstrahlung zu produzieren. Es gibt unterschiedliche Prozesse. Wenn wir von der kosmischen Strahlung reden, dann sind es,
vor allem die hochbeschleunigten Protronen.
Diese hochbeschleunigten Proton, wir wissen nicht, wo die beschleunigt werden, aber die gibt's ja, weil wir wissen ja, dass die auf die Erde kommen, müssen die irgendwo beschleunigt.
Wo müssen sie herkommen, ja.
Und wenn diese hochbeschleunigte Proteine denkt, wo auf Materie treffen, Materie reden wir jetzt entweder von Materie, die andere.
Himmelsquellen umgibt oder Materie, die sind äh vor allem aber Protonen, die in Ruhe sind, die nicht so hohe Energie haben. Das heißt sehr hoch energetische Proton,
stoßen gegenüber nicht so ganz normale Proton, ganz normale Materie und äh dabei entstehen äh Pionen.
Es gibt äh positive Pion, negative Pione und es gibt ja auch neutrale Pionen und diese neutralen Pionen, die es in Garmisch-Strahlung strahlen in Photon, aber dadurch, dass diese Pironnen sehr hohe Energie haben,
weil sie durch Reaktionen von sehr hoch energetischen Protonen zustande gekommen sind, dann haben sie auch es gibt ja Energieerhaltungsgesetze, Energie.
Nicht verloren gehen. Ähm hat äh sehr sehr hohe,
kinetische Energie, die dann ähm also die neutralen zerfallenden in in Garmerstraße. Aber diese Germanung messen wir. Das ist die Hoffnung.
Es gibt einen Alternativprozess wo Protonen gar keine Rolle spielen und trotzdem kriegen wir eine Gamerstrahlung von sehr ähnlich ähm.
Energie in einer sehr ähnlichen Eigenschaft, was das,
Vertrauensspektrum angeht. Also Szenario ist, dass wir nicht Protonen beschleunigen, sondern Elektronen.
Diese Elektronen äh die machen erstmal zehn Cronenstrahlung in Magnetfeldern. Die sehen in Röntgenbereich, im optischen Bereich,
wir wissen, dass da hoch energetische Elektronik da sind und die machen,
Synchronstrahlung, die wir in in optischen Röntgen sehen können. Dann gibt es sogenannte Effekt. Das ist wenn ein äh
Elektron, mit einem Photonen zusammentrifft, der Elektron hat äh viel mehr Energie als Foto und dann wird Energieübertrag äh stattfinden.
Nach der Reaktion wird Foton zu sehr viel höheren Energien beschleunigt wird natürlich nicht beschleunigen. Energie wird.
Übertragen und das Elektron verliert in sogenannter.
Effekt können wir Gamerstrahlung äh bekommen, die,
Energien kommt, die wir mit den messen können. Zwei Alternativszenarien, einmal es gibt äh energetische Proton,
Äh die ähm neutrale Pion.
Produzieren und diese die wir messen oder es gibt,
Elektronik hochenergetisch Elektron die durch Effekt mit niederenergetischen Foton äh wiederum eine Gammerstrahlung machen und das ist die Gammerstrahlung, die wir messen.
Das muss ich jetzt mal ein bisschen sortieren. Also im Sommer äh grob äh zum klammern. Kosmische Strahlung an sich erst mal
ist einfach da. Man kann sie messen, es gibt glaube ich auch auf der ISS dieses Alpha-Magnet äh Spektrummeter, was diese kosmische Strahlung ja auch schon seit zehn Jahren, glaube ich, äh einsammelt. Bin mir jetzt gar nicht so sicher, wie da so die Ergebnislage ist. Also ich habe,
Eine Sendung dazu gemacht, hat sie vor zehn Jahren, da fing das irgendwie alles erst so richtig an da hatte man so ein bisschen die Hoffnung äh äh noch, aber ist ja im Prinzip,
auch so einen Detektor, ne, so der äh einfach lauscht. Wie muss man sich das so vorstellen von der Menge her, also
Wenn die kosmische Strahlung schon ein Problem ist, wenn man fliegt, ist sie das deshalb, weil sie,
So häufig auftritt oder äh ist sie deshalb ein Problem, dass wenn sie einen erwischt, dass ihr dann auch sofort einen Schaden auslöst. Also wie verhält sich das so der Strahlung, die wir von der Sonne erhalten, so in Relation?
Strahlung ähm unterlegt.
Dem Potenzgesetz äh abfallenden Potenzgesetz, das heißt die Anzahl der Teilchen, die kommen. Es ist äh ähm wird immer äh weniger äh mit mit Energie,
Potenzgesetz ist ähm zwei Komma zwei Komma sieben oder zwei Komma acht.
Anzahl der Teilchen ist proportional zu der Energie der Teilchen hoch äh Minus zwei Komma sieben.
Das heißt bei kleinen Energien äh hast du sehr viele,
klein rede ich hier von dann reicht auch ein ähm Detektor mit einem Quadratmeter,
Weiß nicht, äh auswendig, wie wie groß das äh IMS,
zwei ähm Apparatus ist, aber viel viel äh größer wird sich nicht sein. Wir reden hier von.
Ja, so in der Größenordnung. Mhm.
Von von Sotelitenexperimenten ähm das ist sehr teuer und viel viel größer kriegt man's einfach nicht äh nicht mehr hoch,
das heißt mit einem was ungefähr ein Quadratmeter ist äh wirst du schon,
in innerhalb von Monaten und Jahren sehr viel Statistik aufsammeln können. Also zu den höheren Energien äh gehst äh dann durch dieses Potenzgesetz hast du viel, viel weniger Teichen,
teilweise reden wir von den Energien, die wir bereits äh detektiert haben, hier auf der auf der Erde von der Kosmischen Strahlung,
Muss man vielleicht auf einen Quadratkilometer äh so ein paar Jahre warten, bis ein Teich hinkommt.
Auf einem Quadratkilometer ein paar Jahre warten, bis ein einzelnes Teilchen kommt. Okay, das ist ja eher selten. Mhm.
Also das heißt, wenn wenn so ein Teilchen sich trifft, da ähm dann ist es natürlich wieder Wahrscheinlichkeit äh von von irgendwelchen Mutationen,
energetische kosmische Strahlung ist äh ist nicht sehr gefährlich.
Höher energetisch wahrscheinlich gefährlicher aber es geht um ja wahrscheinlich sehe ich so, dass wenn du mit deinem ähm Strahl getroffen wird ist da gleich eine Mutation stattfindet, sondern das ist ja schon,
ein ein Prozessus.
Nicht jede Gamma also nicht nicht die gesamte kosmische Strahlung ist Gammastrahlung.
Die kosmische Strahlung äh besteht vor allem ausgeladenem Proton. Und äh Strahlung ist nur ein Teil davon je weniger.
Und das ist das Gute dabei ist, dass mit der Gammastrahlung äh das ist ein Teil von elektromates Spektrum. Also wird von,
Magnetfeldern nicht abgelenkt mit der Kammerstrahlung kannst du äh Astronomie machen. Die zeigt hier wo die Quelle ist, wo wo ist äh wo ist her?
Geladen äh kosmische Strahlung kann man mit äh Detektoren wie iMS zwei,
gut studieren, wie die Komposition ist, wie viel Protonen, wie viel höhere Teilchen da ist, wie viel Elektron, wie viel Prositon, ob's äh Anti-Materie gibt bei äh bei diesen hohen Energien. Sowas kannst du sehr gut studieren.
Aber die Richtung sagt hier halt sehr sehr wenig, weil äh die ähm geladenen Teichen durch die Magnetfelder.
Gleichmäßig verteilt sind.
Genau, genau.
Was.
Denkt man denn jetzt, was so die Quellen sind? Also wenn es so rätselhaft ist, äh wo diese großen Energien entstehen, was käme denn in Frage? Was äh glaubt man denn, was der Ursprung dieser Strahlung sein könnte?
Es gibt mehrere Hypothesen und man ähm das Spektrum, diese kosmische Strahlung.
Hat auch eine bestimmte Form, die man äh sehr sehr gut äh kennt als Funktion der Energie. Man glaubt, das sind bis zu bestimmten Energien, bis zu sogenannten Knie,
dass die ganzen Beschleuniger hier in unserer Galaxie sind. Äh wahrscheinlich sind es äh Super Nova überreste,
die so hohen Energien kommen aber vielleicht auch andere.
Andere Quellen bei noch höheren Energien werden äh Quellen außerhalb von unserer Galaxie vermutet.
Was die genau sind, ist äh ist bisschen schwierig zu,
Also es ist noch nicht gelungen eindeutig zu festzustellen, was was die was die Quellen sind. Was was noch uns helfen sollte ist jetzt hat mein Projekt jetzt wenig zu tun.
Hat aber mit Multi Messenger Geschichte eher was zu tun, das nicht nur Gamerstrahlung an den,
Stellen entsteht, wo die hochenergetischen Protonen beschleunigt werden, sondern auch Neutrinus. Also es gibt ja äh extra Neutrino-Detektoren und das Beste ist ja Ice Cube.
Und wenn man dort,
Quellen äh Neutrinoquellen außerhalb der Galaxy innerhalb unserer Galaxie finden würde. Das würde eindeutig zu den Quellen der kosmischen Strahlung führen.
Es gibt äh ganz klar äh Beweis, dass ähm dass es Neutrinoquellen gibt.
Aber es ist noch keine Klasse dieser Quellen hervor.
Hervorgetan, dass man jetzt weiß, okay, das ist die Klasse, die Neutrinus macht.
Also generell wir wissen große äh Dinge geschehen mit sehr viel Energien. Das hat uns zumindest auch schon die Gravitationswellen-Astronomie
deutlich gemacht, Kollisionen von Nordronstern, Kollisionen, von schwarzen Löchern oder schwarzen Löchern mit Neutonstern und was äh vielleicht sonst auch noch äh gefunden wird, lässt sich
messen und was du angesprochen hast, die Multi Messenger ähm Astronomie
basiert ja auf diesem Prinzip, dass man eben mehr als nur ein Auge hat. So haben wir bis vor kurzem eigentlich nur in einem ganz normalen, elektromagnetischen Strahlung, sprich Licht, Infrarot, et cetera, Röntgenstrahlung äh gewildert. Dort äh schon sehr guten Eindruck bekommen
von dem Universum ist es halt auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise limitiert,
und durch neue Messmethoden an ganz anderer Effekte wird jetzt quasi so das Besteck,
vergrößert, das das Spektrum der Möglichkeiten in das Universum reinzulauschen, vergrößert.
Wie zum Beispiel eben durch die Gravitationswellen-Astronomie, aber eben auch die
Messung eben der Neutrino, das Ice Cube angesprochen, habe ich ja auch schon mal drüber äh gesprochen, Raumzeit,
73 hat sich damit beschäftigt, wer das noch nicht gehört hat, ist halt so ein riesiger, ja
Eiswürfel tatsächlich äh in der Antarktis quasi einfach so ein äh dunkler Quadratkilometer ganz tief ins ähm ins Eis eingelassen, wo er im Prinzip einfach Licht,
installiert hat und wenn halt irgendwann mal ein Neutrino äh quer von hinten durch die Erde durchschießt und in einem ganz seltenen Fall dann doch mal äh mit der Umgebung interagiert, äh dann gibt's da so ein bisschen blaues Licht und das kann man irgendwie sehen und dann hat man wieder so einen Vektor gewonnen, wo man weiß, so aha okay
da ist jetzt grade was hergekommen äh gucken wir doch mal äh dahin und in dem Moment, wo man in der Lage ist, all diese ganzen Beobachtungen im Idealfall vielleicht sogar auch in Echtzeit,
mehr oder weniger auf dieselbe Stelle auszurichten und mit allen denkbaren Teleskopen und sonstigen Sensoren äh dort äh reinzulauschen
man eben noch sehr viel mehr äh Erkenntnisse bekommen, als man eben derzeit hat und insbesondere wenn man eben nur auf eine einzige Art reinschaut, weil die sich dann gegenseitig bestätigen könnten et cetera oder auch eben äh vom vom Wert her ergänzen können.
Sprich die Hoffnung ist mit den äh Teleskopen hier
ein weiteres Ohr quasi äh noch dazu zu gewinnen auf auf eine andere Quelle äh zu lauschen,
die so bisher nicht detektierbar war und ähm.
Es ist nicht die gesamte äh kosmische Strahlung, die jetzt hier analysiert werden soll, sondern man reduziert sich auf einen bestimmten Bereich und auf einen bestimmten
eben das, was man die Strahlung nennt.
Du das nochmal eingrenzen, was genau jetzt sozusagen der Fokus dieser Teleskope sein soll.
Vielleicht bisschen zu vertiefen, zu Verständnis.
Die Teleskoppe heißen Sharingkauf-Teleskope, auf Englisch äh äh Teleskop.
Hier geht's um die Idee oder die Technik ähm die Gamerstrahlung zu messen. Also wir wir messen zwar im Endeffekt das Pflicht.
Aber uns interessiert das Sharingkauflicht äh eigentlich gar nicht. Das ist ja nur so ein so ein Werkzeug. Ähm um das Werkzeug ist da, um die Kammerstrahlung,
zu studieren, äh zu messen, zu verstehen, wo woher sie kommt, aus welchen Quellen sie kommt und dann natürlich zusammen mit äh anderen Wellenlängen und mit Multi Messenger,
Informationen zu verstehen, wie wie das Ganze funktioniert.
Lässt sich den Gamma-Strahlung als solche nicht einfach messen?
Genau äh man kann es relativ äh einfach messen. Ähm nur die Atmosphäre äh ist ein Schild für uns diese Gammerstrahlung kommt da nicht durch. Am einfachsten ist ein mit Satelliten hochzugehen und die Kammerstrahlung,
ist ist das beste Instrument, was wir haben, sei seit mehr als zehn Jahren funktioniert hervorragend, aber ist wieder so ein Satelliten, das heißt ähm ist wieder so ein,
Instrument, was nur ein Quadratmeter groß ist,
Das heißt bei höheren Energien der Garmastrahlung ist diese Fläche einfach nicht groß genug.
Muss die größer sein.
Weil die äh Kammerstrahlung, sowie die kosmische Strahlung auch äh einem Potenzgesetz als Funktion der Energie äh unterliegt und die Anzahl der Teichen mit höheren Energien einfach sehr sehr gering ist.
Also man braucht mehr Fläche zum Detektieren.
Entweder man wartet 100 Jahre mit diesem Gerät, dass da jemand äh etwas vorbeifliegt oder man braucht ein ein Fußballfeld. Und da kommt die Teleskope oder diese Technik ähm.
Sehr äh sehr sehr gut an. Bei höheren Energien,
Das ist nicht neu, sie wurde in fünfziger, sechziger, 70er Jahren letzten Jahrhunderts entwickelt.
Und äh es es war eine Generation von von Experimenten, vielleicht erstmal ein Wipple in Arizona, dann ähm als zweite Generation,
von den äh äh Teleskopen, die hießen äh auch wieder Ripple, dann äh.
Hekra war hier auf La Palma mit fünf Teleskopen.
Wurde das erste Mal Steroskopische Messprinzip,
ähm ausprobiert und bewiesen, dass es gut geht. Da geht's darum, dass man nicht nur mit einem,
Challenge Teleskoping vorhin guckt, sondern mit mehreren, ich erkläre gleich, äh wie wie es funktioniert.
Dann kam die nächste Generation von die ist nach wie vor funktionieren. Da sind magic wiederum hier auf La Palma. Hesse aus Namibia und wäre das in ähm.
In Arizona und die funktionieren noch ganz gut. Ähm.
Aber die sind mittlerweile so gut, dass man sagt, es ist äh es ist an der Zeit ein Absolvatorium zu zu bauen. Es ist ein es reicht das als Experiment zu betreiben. Also was heißt als Experiment zu betreiben? Das heißt,
paar Institute schließen sich zusammen mit das heißt vielleicht 10200 Wissenschaftler und Ingenieure,
bauen etwas betreiben das selber,
Daten auf analysieren die Daten und publizieren das. Die Daten an sich bleiben Eigentum von von dem Projekt, von dem Experiment.
Das funktioniert aber mit diesem Channel auf Teleskopen. Mittlerweile so gut, dass man vor 1 oder 15 Jahren gesagt hat, okay, lass uns mal einen Schritt weiter,
so wie es äh mal bei optischen Teleskopen äh passiert ist, ist wie ein Abservatorium machen, dass wir ein Gerät bauen und das betreiben als offenes Observatorium, dass wir Ausschreibungen machen und jeder, der sich,
äh für Garmastrahlung interessiert, keiner ein ein Schreiben und äh wenn sie die Idee gut ist,
dann werden Daten genommen und dann werden die Daten präpariert, analysiert und derjenige,
der ähm die Idee hatte, kriegt die Daten und kann sie dann publizieren. Und wer es innerhalb von einem Jahr, sagen wir mal, nicht gemacht hat, dann sind die Daten öffentlich für alle, die da danach auch nicht gefragt haben.
Mhm. Okay, also wir haben hier sozusagen jetzt mehrere äh äh Vektoren, über die wir hier sprechen. Zunächst einmal, ich fasse das mal so ein bisschen mit meinen Worten zusammen. Ähm
Gamerstrahlung messen, Gammerstrahlung ist interessant, Kammerstrahlung hat hohe Energien und wo äh hohe Energien auf uns einprasseln, dann äh lässt es darauf schließen, dass da irgendwo was passiert ist und das wollen wir wissen. So das ist erstmal das Grundinteresse, so. Mal ganz unabhängig davon, welche der Theorien was es jetzt ist
letztlich eintritt, ne? Ob's aus irgendwelchen schwarzen Löchern kommt oder was auch immer, es kommt, das wissen wir und wir wollen's irgendwie messen und äh
Ziel ist jetzt vor allem auch mittelfristig möglichst vielen Wissenschaftlern eine Tür zu öffnen, solche Messungen durchzuführen. Jetzt sind diese,
technisch äh über die letzten Jahrzehnte entwickelt worden und man weiß, okay alles klar, die funktionieren im Prinzip.
Einfacher in Anführungsstrichen, wenn auch sehr viel teurer und aufwendiger ist, ist das Ganze im All zu machen. Das Fami Gameray, Space Teleskop, die du erwähnt hast, gibt's halt irgendwie,
zehn, 12 Jahren ist noch ein Betrieb, ne? Genau.
Ist. Äh auch hier ist wieder das Wort large. Äh noch mal im Namen eigentlich noch mit drin. Also vorher war das zumindest so. Es geht einfach dadrum, viel Fläche zu machen, weil einfach der Effekt, den man einsammeln will,
selten ist und umso größer man sich natürlich ausbreitet, umso besser ist es. Am liebsten würde man wahrscheinlich eine komplette äh komplettes Land äh oder eine komplette Wüste damit zu kleben, aber
Das äh wird natürlich dann zu äh teuer und stört zu viele Leute. Also muss man irgendwie anders rangehen. Aber aufm Boden, wo man dann eben mehr Platz hätte, hat man dann wiederum den Feind der Atmosphäre, die Atmosphäre
schluckt die Gamma-Strahlung, aber wenn aber nicht unbedingt komplett, sondern irgendwas bleibt über und über diesen Cherrenkov-Effekt,
kann man diese Behinderung umgehen,
Wie macht man das, warum funktioniert das und was genau misst ihr so einen Teleskop?
Ja es ist ganz ähm ist ganz interessant, dass wir die Atmosphäre als äh,
Teil der Messung oder ein Teil des äh des Teleskops betrachten. Äh in der Tat ist es so, dass wenn die kosmische Strahlung oder die Gaumerstrahlung bei diesen hohen Energien in die Atmosphäre eintrifft.
Die Atmosphäre unser Schuldschild. Aber es passiert auch so, dass sie äh die die wenn die Gamer-Strahlen auf die Atmosphäre treffen,
entstehen neue Teilchen diese ist natürlich wiederum Energieerhaltungsgesetz, das heißt äh die neue Teiche, die entstanden sind, die haben sehr hohe Energie.
Die geladenen Teichen,
von äh den Kammerstrahlung in den Energien, von denen wir hier reden herkommen, die ähm bereiten sich in der Atmosphäre schneller als die Lichtgeschwindigkeit in der Atmosphäre. Natürlich ist die Lichtgeschwindigkeit im Vakuum, das Maximum,
man erreichen kann,
Lichtgeschwindigkeit äh im Medium, in der Atmosphäre, im Wasser ist ist nicht gleich der ähm Ausbreitungsgeschwindigkeit im Vakuum,
können diese geladenen Teichen in der Atmosphäre schneller sein als das Licht äh in der Atmosphäre.
Und dadurch entsteht so eine Art Macheffekt, was man vom Akustik kennt. Äh diesmal ähm mit diesen Teichen, die die Moleküle, die die atmosphärischen Moleküle können sich nicht,
relaxieren und da gibt's ein ein Nettoeffekt ah was so was dann äh heißt oder Effekt äh resultiert in äh einem kurzen Strahlungblitz,
was in unter einem bestimmten Winkel entlang der Ausbreitung von diesen geladenen Teichen entsteht.
Und äh ähm diese Strahlung, die ist irgendwo in ultravioletten oder im optischen. Das heißt, man braucht eigentlich nur so ein optisches äh Teleskop.
Hinstellen, was was gar nicht irgendwelche Sterne beobachtet, sondern man beobachtet die Atmosphäre und äh passiert was. Da leuchtet kurz was auf, also so wie wir Macheffekt.
Optischen.
Macheffekt genau.
Ähm Schalleffekt äh wenn so ein Flugzeug über die Schallwäld.
Schallmauer, so eine optische Schallmauer, die durchbrochen wird.
So so ungefähr, genau. Und äh man beobachtet diesen Blitz in der Atmosphäre äh mit mit einem optischen Teleskop. Das ähm,
Besondere hier ist, dass dieser Blitz sehr kurz ist. Äh wir reden hier von Nanosekum, das heißt ähm die die Exposure äh muss sehr sehr kurz sein.
Wir reden hier von irgendwelchen zehn, 20, 30 Nanosekunden Belichtungszeit von jedem.
Von jenem Ereignis, also nochmal Gamerstrahl kommt in die Atmosphäre rein, es gibt äh unterschiedliche Prozesse, einige von denen entstehen der geladenen Teichen.
Sogenanntes Schauer bilden, bereiten sich in die Richtung des ursprünglichen Teiches mehr oder weniger, natürlich unter bestimmten Winkeln.
Und diese geladenen Teichen bereiten sich schneller als die Lichtgeschwindigkeit in der Atmosphäre aus.
Also nicht schneller als die Lichtgeschwindigkeit, wie sie mit C definiert ist, sondern nur schneller als das Licht, das eine Atmosphäre schafft sich auszubrennen.
Wir reden von diesem Index N, was äh 1 Komma0null irgendwas eins ist, aber das reicht schon.
Mhm. Okay.
Reicht schon aus und äh der Index der sagt um uns auch,
ja für unter welchem Winkel die Strahlung ausgestrahlt wird. Beispiel im Wasser ist es relativ großer Winkel in der Atmosphäre ist ungefähr ein Grad.
Passiert was in der Atmosphäre, da gibt's so diese ähm Teilchen Schauer von geladenen Teilchen, was aber bei unseren Energien von der ursprünglichen Teichen ungefähr im Maximum auf zehn Kilometer über dem Meeresniveau hat.
Ungefähr drei, vier Kilometer über dem Meeresniveau ausstirbt,
ein Gamerstrahl oder geladenes Teilchen kommt in die Atmosphäre rein macht ein Teilchenschauer, der stirbt. Das heißt weil die Atmosphäre ist oder einfach auch einsammelt, auch absorbiert.
Über welche Strecke lässt sich dann dieser Blitz sehen? Also wie wie lange ist sozusagen die Strecke, wo der Blitz zu sehen ist?
Das ist so ein im Himmel ähm,
irgendwo entstanden äh in oberen Schichten der Atmosphäre, man hat Maximum, Anzahl der Teichen ungefähr auf zehn Kilometer über einem äh Meeresniveau und dann ist es irgendwann abgestorben. Und äh alle geladenen Teichen.
In diesem gleichen Schauer haben gemacht. Und jedes Teilchen macht dann so einen so einen Ring auf der.
Auf den Grund hier vielleicht äh hier zum Beispiel auf 2000 Meter über dem Meeresniveau. Und die Überlagerung äh von diesen äh Ringen macht uns das sogenannte Chillen of Pool,
Pool hat äh ein Radius von ungefähr 120 Metern,
wir reden hier von einer Fläche, die ähm von wenn wir von Senkrechten eingetroffenen Gaumastrahlung reden,
ein Kreis von äh Radius 120 Meter reden. Davor haben wir geredet,
Gamerstrahl, ähm das Gerät treffen muss, was vielleicht ein Quadratmeter ist von so einem Satelliten. Hier,
mit einem einzelnen Gamerstrahl leuchtest du eine Fläche mit dem Radius von 120 Meter. Egal wo in diese Fläche,
eine steht kann es ein Foto von einem Teichenschauer machen in dem von diesem Teilchen schaue,
und dann rekonstruieren, was das für ein Teilchenschauer war,
was der Ursprung von diesem Teichenschauer war, ob's jetzt ein Kammerstrahl oder oder ein kosmischer Strahl war, aus welche Richtung es gekommen ist und welche Energie es ursprünglich hatte.
Was genau ist der Detektor in dem
Teleskop. Also diese Teleskope haben mich ein bisschen überrascht, weil die nicht diese typische Schutzkuppel haben. Die stehen irgendwie relativ äh frei da rum. Da ist es irgendwie ein bisschen egal, ob da Wind und Wetter drauf sich äh äh abspielt.
Also im Wesentlichen so eine Gerüststruktur, auf die dann ein relativ großer Spiegel ähm montiert ist. Ich weiß nicht, was der Durchmesser von dem LST, von dem Großen jetzt.
Den Durchmesser von 23 Metern.
23 Meter, also ziemlich fettes Teil. Ähm wo dann äh vorne so ein äh Detektor,
an so einem langen Bogen Elepsid.
Ja wir haben dann.
Also was genau wird da dann gesehen? Also wir reden jetzt von blauem Licht dem dem Frequenzbereich so das muss gesehen werden.
Grobes ja äh es ist ein relativ einfaches Teleskop-Prinzip, man man hat da einen parapoolischen Spiegel von in unserem Fall dreiundzwanzig ähm,
Durchmesser äh Reflektor besteht aus einzelnen Spiegeln, weil man äh es ist einfach unbezahlbar 23 Meter mit einem Spiegel zu machen. Wir haben,
2hundert Einzelner spiegelt dieses Auspflastern müssen wir auch natürlich äh einzeln ausrichten.
Müssen wir das von diesem Teich anschauen, was nicht hängt, wo Lichtjahre entfernt passierte, sondern.
Zehn Kilometer.
Kilometer oder 8 Kilometer über uns. Wir sind auf 2tausend Meter.
Dieses Licht müssen wir in einer Kamera äh fokussieren und mit dieser Kamera machen wir dann ein äh ein Foto.
Belichtungszeit von diesem Foto muss sehr kurz sein, weil natürlich kann man länger belichten, aber das Interessante äh ist innerhalb von paar anderen Sekunden, wenn wir sehr viel integrieren, dann,
sammeln mal sehr viel Untergrund und dann können wir dieses,
das schwache Licht von der nicht mehr von dem Hintergrund äh trennen,
ist es sehr wichtig äh kurze Belichtungszeit äh zu haben und da sind so die die üblichen Kameras, die man bei der optischen Astronomie verwendet, obwohl das Licht in einem optischen Spektrum ist,
äh noch nicht so weit, weil diese Belichtungszeiten von Mikrosikonen oder oder Millisekunden haben,
und da kommt uns ein Foto sehr zugute, das heißt.
Du hast ein Photon, was von der ein Elektronik auslöst, dann hast du dahinter,
eine elektrisches Feld, was das durch Foto äh Effekt ausgelöst hat, beschleunigst und da gibt's ein System von Dinoden, die aus einem Elektron,
zehn, hundert und so weiter machen machst äh wir machen Verstärkung von ungefähr 40.000 von äh das heißt von einem einzelnen.
Äh
Ein ein messbares, elektrisches Signal äh sehen, ähm was dann durch eine bestimmte Elektronik oder Triggerektronik und Elektroelektronik durchgeht und und und das Messer, das heißt ein Foto,
und die Technik ist ist relativ vielleicht 8000 Jahre muss ich nachgucken.
Und äh das das äh das funktioniert sehr gut. Was auch äh wichtig für uns ist, dass wir sehr hohe Quanteneffizienz haben, weil wir wirklich.
So viele einsammeln wollen, wie wir können. Es ist nie so wie so ein Teleskop, wo wir Hauptsache sehr präzise, aber wir können sehr viel Licht verlieren, nein, wir können kein Licht verlieren, versuchen alles reinzusammeln, so ein Foto Multiplayer hat.
Quanteneffizienz von ungefähr 40 Prozent zurzeit. 40 Prozent heißt, du hast ein einzelnes äh optisches Foto und was auf die Kathode trifft, hast vierzig Prozent,
Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du ein messbares Signal davon bekommst. Also schon,
schon sehr, sehr hoch. Wir reden hier von wirklich von einzelnen optischen Motoren, die wir detektieren wollen.
Ich versuch's nochmal ein bisschen äh aus meiner Perspektive äh zusammenzufassen. Also wir haben die Gamerstrahlung, die trifft jetzt auf die Atmosphäre. Atmosphäre fängt halt, na ja, gibt's ja nicht so einen klaren Bereich. Sie wird halt immer dichter.
Sagt bei 100 Kilometern über der Erdoberfläche fängt irgendwie so das Universum an, da ist man dann in Space
ab da verdichtet sich die Atmosphäre in einem nennenswerten Maße, sagen wir es mal so, wird dann halt immer dichter und das steigt natürlich dann auch exponentiell an.
Bei zehn Kilometer ist so viel Molekülmaterial vorhanden, dass diese Gammastrahlung dann interagiert und
tut sie, indem sie halt dort auftrifft und durch diesen Effekt, den du schon beschrieben hast, dass äh hier diese äh diese Übertragung der Energie der Gammastrahlung auf die Moleküle so einen Effekt auslöst, dass es dann eben
schneller ist als das Licht, hat es eben so eine Art Fotoschockwellen-Effekt, der dann eben in einem Blitz resultiert, der in einem großen
Kanal, also in so einem
Du hast gesagt elipsoid, also ähm ich stelle mir das halt einfach jetzt so wie so ein Lichtstrahl aus einer Taschenlampe äh vorab dem Moment, der dann irgendwie auf dem Boden zumindest auf der Höhe, wo wir jetzt hier in La Palma mit den Teleskopen lauschen, nach acht Kilometern
ungefähr einen Bereich ausleuchtet von 120 Metern und wenn halt zufällig das Teleskop genau in diesem.
Abstrahlbereich steht, dann kann dieser Blitz aufgenommen werden und das wird er dadurch, dass man im Prinzip mit diesen
Foto, Multiplayer-Detektoren äh über diesen Spiegel einfach die ganze Zeit nach oben schaut und äh eigentlich ist es ja mehr so eine Art Videokamera. Man möchte ja möglichst eine hohe zeitliche Auflösung des Lichtverlaufs.
Ne bis auf Nanosekunden runter, damit man einfach äh nicht nur einen äh hier war ein Lichtblitz,
Dass man eben diesen Lichtblitz auch in seinem gesamten Verlauf sehr fein,
messen kann, wahrscheinlich auch, um dann einfach auch die Richtung der ursprünglichen Gamerstrahlung da wieder herauslesen zu können. Stimmt das so in etwa?
Ich möchte kurz korrigieren zu dieser ja Teilchenschauer, heißt fast äh fast alles äh sehr gut verstanden. Ähm.
Nur dass die Atmosphäre sich verdichtet, ist ein wichtiger Effekt ähm aber man man soll es vielleicht bisschen anders verstehen äh wie so ein Teilchenschau ähm entsteht.
Wenn Gamerstrahlung kosmische Strahlung auf die Atmosphäre trifft, wo sie erst äh Interaktion stattfindet, das ist nicht unbedingt zehn Kilometer, das ist irgendwo viel weiter höher.
Aus einem Teich in äh das macht halt irgendwie so ein so ein ultrarelastivistisches Elektronik aus einem,
was da irgendwo ganz oben ist,
machst du zwei, weil sie dann wieder interagieren mit irgendwelchen Molekülen oder durch Bremsstrahlung und Bremsstrahlung äh reagiert mit Molekülen der Atmosphäre. Haus zwei mal vier, aus vier macht,
acht aus acht mal sechzehn. Also es ist wirklich so eine Teilchenkaskade. Natürlich die Energie pro Teichen halbiert sich auch jedes.
Und äh und dieses Gebilde, was wir Teichen Schauer nennen, das wächst in ganze Zeit an bis ungefähr auf zehn Kilometer und dann stirbt das Haus, das heißt.
Da wird's dann wieder kleiner.
Genau, weil die neuen neuen stehenden Teichen nicht genug Energie haben, um neue Teilchen zu machen oder sind dann nicht mehr ultra.
Okay, das heißt, dieser gesamte ausgeleuchtete Bereich sozusagen dann ein großes Elipsoide, weil es da oben mal an einer Stelle beginnt, sich ausbreitet bis zehn Kilometer und dann wird's wieder dünner.
Und das ganze Ding, dieses dieses opsoid, was da eigentlich vorher in der Atmosphäre ähm stattfindet, das macht,
jedes Teilchen jedes geladene Teilchen, was schneller ins Lichtgeschwindigkeit in der Atmosphäre ist, macht Licht und äh das macht insgesamt dann,
diesen Detektoroberfläche.
Das heißt, es ist es ist wertvoll mit den Teleskopen auch möglichst hoch zu sein.
Zehn Kilometer ist nur so so ein Richtwert und es gibt natürlich äh Schauer, die weiter runterkommen,
man hat auch eine Idee gehabt, Teleskope vielleicht auch fünf Kilometer,
ähm ja zu bauen und da hat man festgestellt, okay das ist dann nicht unbedingt einfacher,
zu detektieren, also bei kleinen Energien, da wo die wo das Maximum von weiter oben ist, ist es einfacher,
aber bei höheren Energien kommt dieses Maximum von Teichenschau weiter unten und da bist du.
Mit deinem Teleskop noch sozusagen innerhalb der Entwicklung von diesem Teilchenschauer und da ist,
Detektion vielleicht einfacher aber die Rekonstruktion von dem was du siehst ist schwieriger.
Okay. Also könnte es sein, dass sogar die zweieinhalb Kilometer, die wir hier auf La Palma haben, so ein.
So ziemlich ähm genau, also zwischen ähm tausend7 800 Meter und äh zweieinhalb Kilometern, also Sweet Spot, wo das äh ganz gut funktioniert.
Und wie kann man jetzt aus dem gemessenen Licht mit dieser hohen Auflösung den Ursprung der Gammerstrahlung, also die Richtung, wirklich die die Quelle, wie kann man die daraus äh rechnen?
Diese Kamera von äh Sharingkauf Teleskop besteht aus äh nicht nur aus einem Photomulti, sondern aus mehreren, die von Magic ungefähr tausend Photomoly Play jetzt äh,
mittlerweile 2000 Foto-Multi-Planern, das heißt, du hast pixualisiertes Bild.
Und äh in diesem Vergleich mal zu iPhone Kamera ist natürlich nicht viel zu als 2000 Kanäle, aber das reicht uns aus,
zu rekonstruieren und am besten kommt dann noch die uns zu Hilfe,
euer Machmann ein äh ein Bild von diesem Teilchenschauer, nicht mit einem Teleskop, sondern mit zwei und das ist dann so wie.
Zwei Augen schauen.
Zu Augen und äh am besten drei oder vier, dann machst du Bild von einem selben Teichenschau aus unterschiedlichen Richtungen und dann äh während der Analyse der Daten kannst du die Bilder kombinieren,
dann viel besser rekonstruieren, wo genau Teichenschauer stattgefunden hat. Weil sonst hast du nur die Richtung, wo das Ding ist, da ist ein bisschen,
ähm Ambiguität äh ob's äh nach links oder nach rechts schaut,
Aber von mehreren Richtungen des ähm selben Schauteichen Schauer fotografiert hast, dann äh ist die Rekonstruktion einfacher und ähm die die Hauptachse von diesem elepsoiden.
Das ist die äh Richtung, aus der entweder kosmische Strahl oder ähm Gamerstrahl gekommen ist,
dadurch rekonstruierst du die Richtung, wo es hergekommen ist und je größer des Teichenschauers sagt dir was über die Energie.
Mhm. Weil umso mehr Power umso größer ist dieser Illipsoid.
Genau und dann hast du pro Bild, was du analysierst Energie und und Richtung.
Das heißt, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, also erstmal der also der Detektor ist nicht nicht einer, sondern wie du gesagt hast, eine eine Matrix und dadurch kann man schon mal einen zeitlichen Verlauf feststellen, weil.
Sieht so ein bisschen schräg äh ist, dann schlägt der eine TikTok vielleicht etwas früher an als der als der andere innerhalb eines Teleskopdetektors, ja, habe ich das richtig verstanden?
Wäre ich hier äh nein nein.
Oder sind die mehreren Detektoren nur ums besser, das Licht besser empfangen zu können?
Ist es eher Richtungsinformation, die äh die du brauchst. Natürlich äh wir reden hier von Schauerfront,
Das heißt äh Teilchenschauer imitiert das Licht, das Licht breitet sich aus mit der Lichtgeschwindigkeit.
Im Medium und äh wenn du wenn die Teleskope nicht unbedingt ähm zum Zenit gucken, sondern Zenitwinkel, sagen wir mal dreißig Grad,
werden bestimmte Teleskope früher getroffen als als andere.
Diese Information wird in der Analyse verwendet, aber das ist nicht die Hauptinformation, die wir brauchen. Hauptsache,
was wichtig ist, ist sie Richtung, aus welcher.
Die äh Photos kommen so äh über die Richtung können wir viel besser.
Okay, aber meine Frage war, kann jetzt äh also wenn ich jetzt nur ein Teleskop habe,
dort aber mehrere Foto quasi so ein also eine Matrix von von Detektoren habe. Kann ich,
dadurch, dass ich mehrere äh dieser Fotomultiplayer habe schon die Richtung dadurch herausfinden mit einem einzelnen Teleskop oder ist das eigentlich erst mit mehreren Teleskopen möglich.
Es ist in der Tat möglich, mit einem Teleskop zu machen, ist aber ist aber schwierig, es ist wirklich es sind zwei Effekte, die gegeneinander spielen. Das äh das heißt.
Die zeitliche Entwicklung in einem bestimmten Bild äh ist dadurch ähm zustande gekommen, das ähm Teil.
Dieses eher von den Photonen kommt wir nennen das von einem von äh also von einem Kopf äh von diesem Teilchenschauer und der andere kommt von dem von dem.
Nun kann man sich das geometrisch so vorstellen, dass die äh Photonen, die von dem kommen, die kommen, äh die gehen auf dem direkten Weg zu uns.
Die äh Photonen, die von dem kommen die ähm da ist erstmal eine Schauentwicklung,
die zustande kommen muss und da und erst danach werden die äh von einem imitiert. Das heißt rein geometrisch würde man erwarten, dass die Photonen von einem.
Er uns treffen als die Photonen von einem. Also so wie wir sind.
Noch mal ein Delay drin ist, ja.
Dreieck. Das eine kommt von der Hypotiuse, das andere kommt von diesen zwei.
Zwei Katheten sozusagen. Nun äh ist es aber nicht unbedingt so, weil Teichen schauen Entwicklung geht schneller zustande als die Ausbreitung des Lichts äh im in der Atmos.
Kann es schon kompensiert werden. Deswegen die zeitliche Struktur in dem Bild, was wir beobachten ist zwar wichtig,
kann aber nicht eindeutig oder nicht immer eindeutig zugeordnet werden und das hängt dann äh damit zusammen, wie nah äh Teichenschauer zu dem Teleskop.
Stattfindet, ob's ob's jetzt nah dran ist oder weiter weg ist, dass es weiter weg ist, dann ist es ähm einfacher die zeitliche Struktur in dem Bild,
einzuordnen, wenn's in der Nähe dran ist, dann ist es.
Okay, verstehe. Das heißt, das Teleskop selber äh verwendet diese mehreren Fotomultiplayer und diese hohe Auflösung in der Dedition, um überhaupt erstmal die Struktur selber dieses Elipsowets möglichst gut
abzubilden und wenn man jetzt
vor allem darauf aus und das ist man ja im Prinzip auch noch die unmittelbare Herkunft, der ursprünglich das des ganzen auslösenden Gammastrahlung möglichst genau zu vermessen. Dann ist es praktisch, wenn man noch mehrere solche Teleskope,
in unmittelbarer Nähe aber auch hat. Also die tatsächlich in,
Umkreis von 120 Meter stehen, aber da passt ja gar nicht so viel hin eigentlich hundert1zwanzig Meter. Ist ja nicht so viel, wenn man jetzt selber einen Teleskop hat, was schon mal 23 Meter Durchmesser hat.
Richtig, also es ist ganz äh ganz scharf äh beobachtet. Ähm deswegen,
von den die wir bauen wir nur vier weil passender auch einfach nicht mehr rein.
Okay, aber das ist sozusagen das Ziel. Vier zu bauen, die alle möglichst nah beieinander sind.
Genau, wenn wir es hier bauen, wir wollen wirklich, dass das äh selbe äh Teichenschauer von möglichst allen Vieren auch gesehen wird. Natürlich,
wenn Teichenschauer irgendwie an der Seite von diesem runterkommt,
kann sein, dass nur zwei oder nur drei von den vier sehen. Es ist trotzdem ganz gut, aber wenn alle vier sehen, ist äh ist wunderbar. Jetzt baut man aber nicht nur eine Ray von 120 Meter,
Radio, sondern man möchte eher so um zehn Quadratkilometer damit zupflastern,
Da ist es natürlich so, dass du ein Teichenschauer nicht von dem ganzen Reh sehen kannst, sondern nur ein Teil von diesem,
dieses eine sehen können. Nur dadurch, dass du ja größeres Ray hast von zehn Quadratkilometern,
ein anderes Ereignis wird woanders gesehen. Also deine Detektorfläche ist dann ist dann größer. Das ist so wie.
Detektorfläche von dem ein Quadratmeter ist schon besser als ähzehn Quadratzentimeter.
Deine effektive Fläche von einem Instrument wird größer. Je größere Fläche du mit den Teleskopen zupflasterst.
Im Idealfall, ähm wenn Geld keine Rolle spielt, hättet ihr am liebsten irgendwo so eine Fläche in der Wüste, wo einfach,
Platz ist und äh ihr würdet alles voll mit diesen Teleskop Vollpflastern bis äh zum Horizont.
Wenn dann irgendwie die kosmische Strahlung kommt, dann würden zwar vielleicht maximal vier oder fünf irgendwie was sehen, aber auch das wäre ja eine Information, also hätte man da auf einmal einen riesigen Schauer und man würde an mehreren Stellen
äh entdecken, dann wüssten wir ja auch, dass äh jetzt nicht nur so ein Event aufgetreten ist, sondern dass es auch noch im Kontext mit anderen steht, dass da eine höhere Aktivität ist et cetera.
Genau. Das ist das Konzept von diesem Challenge of Teleskopery, das äh ein bisschen dieses Trade-off,
ähm zwischen dem vorhandenen Geld und ähm äh diese Technik äh zuzufinden ist bei geht's darum,
große Teleskope zu bauen mit großem Spiegel, mit sehr Fotodetektoren,
Weil wir reden hier von niederjedischer hochenergetischer Kammerstrahlung. Das heißt, es gibt genug von dem,
Wir müssen nur äh einen Detektor bauen, was äh diese äh Strahlung äh vor dem Hintergrund unterscheiden kann,
Es gibt genug, die so ein 120 Meter Radiusfläche reicht uns vollkommen aus. Bei höheren Energien ist es schon besser,
oder wichtiger,
mehr Fläche mit den Teleskopen zu zu pflastern, weil gibt's einfach nicht mehr so viele, die die runterkommen oder wir müssen entweder sehr lange warten oder höhere Fläche mit den Teleskopen zu pflastern,
bei ganz hohen Energien, äh die wir messen können mit dieser Technik.
Da jedes Zeichen schaue, macht so viel Licht aus, da brauchst du kein äh Hochsynstitius Teleskop um das messen zu können. Es gibt genug Licht.
Aber die sind sehr selten. Da geht's nur darum äh Fläche mit ähm mit mit äh kleinen Teleskopen zuzupflastern.
Ähm wir haben's jetzt schon eingangs so ein bisschen äh erwähnt, aber vielleicht können wir das nochmal kurz zusammenfassen, was es bisher gab und wo es hingehen soll. Also die ersten experimentellen ähm Teleskope waren diese Hegra äh Teleskope hier jetzt auf La Palma.
Und später wurde die beiden Magic, Magic eins, Magic zwei,
quasi schon mal dieses Prinzip abgebildet haben. Zwei, die direkt nebeneinander stehen, um sozusagen die selbe.
Wurde schon bei ähm entwickelt, weil da waren äh da gab's fünf Teleskope, die in einem System zusammengearbeitet haben.
Die waren viel kleiner.
Viel kleiner. Genau und da hat man ähm daraus das waren glaube ich fünf Quadratmeter zehn Quadratmeter Spiegel, muss man nachsehen,
waren fünf von diesen Teleskopen die ja im System gearbeitet haben und dieses Stereoskopie,
entwickelt haben und daraus hat man zwei Experimente gemacht, einmal Magic,
gesagt hat, okay jetzt lass uns mal höre äh größere Teleskope bauen mit mit äh größerer Spiegelfläche Magic Teleskope haben,
Spiegelfläche von siebzehn.
Metern, Durchmesser ähm und da hat man äh das Geld nur für das eine gehabt und da hat man gehofft, auch mit einem Teleskop,
mit großem äh dann zu kleineren Energien zu zu kommen und und die messen zu können und das andere Experiment wurde dann in Namibia gebaut mit vier Teleskopen 12 Meter Durchmesser.
Ähm das dann im Süd äh Kimisphäre äh gearbeitet hat. Es hat auch ähm sehr viele Erfolge.
Gefeiert und bei Magic hat man dann ähm Geld gefunden, um das zweite Teleskop bauen zu können, weil natürlich sterroskopisch,
funktioniert es viel besser und äh ja es sind so zwei beide Kinder von von dem Experiment.
Mhm. Also jetzt stehen da zwei Magics nebeneinander und daneben steht jetzt das LST eins, dem halt noch ein LST zwei, drei und vier, dann äh folgen soll, äh dann werden die Magics dann entfernt und oder bleiben die stehen?
Eine sehr interessante Frage, die ähm lange diskutiert wird äh an sich. Ähm.
Teleskope weiter bestehen, solange LST oder noch nicht äh voll funktionsfähig ist. Aber auch danach ähm.
Gibt es ähm sehr gute Argumente Magic Teleskop äh weiter betreiben zu können oder betreiben zu wollen, weil diese Technik, die ähm zwar.
Die neuen Teleskope, die werden viel sensitiver sein und viel besser funktionieren. Nur das Gesichtsfeld von seinem Sharingkauf Teleskop ist sehr begrenzt.
Hier von,
Gesichtsfeld von drei bis äh bis 8 Grad. Das heißt äh nur in die Richtung von drei bis 8 Grad, wo die Zieleskope gucken, da werden die Ereignisse ja fotografieren können.
Registrieren können und analysieren können. Wenn wir etwas Spannendes woanders passiert und ähm die Quellen oder Quellen von Gammastrahlung,
sind äh teilweise sehr variabel und wir wissen nicht wann die losgehen und wann die aufhören. Ah dann dann kriegen wir davon nichts mit.
Wie nicht mehr fliegt, das fliegt ja schon so zwölf Jahren, geht mal vielleicht kaputt,
dann haben wir vielleicht auch gar kein Instrument in ähnlichen Energien,
was man sagen kann, da passiert was. Guck mal hin. Und da wäre ein äh solche Teleskope wie von Magic oder wäre das oder oder Hess sehr hilfreich, um bestimmte Objekte,
zu Monitoren dann Zeit hinzugucken und dann.
So eine Art System für das hoch.
Mhm. Mhm.
Liefern. Sonst ähm ist man nur darauf angewiesen äh konstante Quellen zu gucken oder äh zufällig etwas zu entdeck.
Verstehe schon. Ich hatte jetzt nur Sorge, dass es da nicht genug Platz gibt, aber äh offensichtlich äh es scheint noch Platz zu sein für die anderen. Drei Teleskope, selbst wenn man die Magic Teleskope da stehen lässt, aber das steht ja alles relativ nah bei
beieinander, aber ich habe mir das äh gerade auch nochmal angeschaut, also das ist schon auch ein bisschen Platz.
Ja, es hängt äh davon ab, unter welchen Senitwinkeln äh Quellen beobachtet werden, wenn man zu relativ hohen Senitwinkeln geht, dann äh ist dieses äh sogenannte Shadowing Effekte schon da. Also da ist es in der Tat.
Ein weniges Problem, dass äh wir nicht so viel Platz haben und das Magic Teleskop äh vielleicht äh ein bisschen.
Im Weg stehen, aber wenn wir äh Beobachtungen unter Kleinsinneln reden, dann äh gibt's kein Shadowing, das äh ist kein Problem.
Also kleiner heißt relativ hoch schauen.
Genau, also alles, was unter sagen wir mal 45 Grad stattfindet, da stehen sie sich nicht im Wege.
Also fünfundvierzig Grad, also null Grad wäre nach oben.
Null Grad wäre nach oben, 45 Grad wäre Hälfte da vorne. Und 90 wäre da in Richtung Chorison.
Gibt es denn bestimmte Orte in unserer Galaxis, die jetzt
permanenten hohen Output an äh Gammastrahlungen haben, wo es sich lohnt sozusagen die ganze Zeit auch hinzuschauen. Dann hat man eine Ahnung, was sich dahinter äh verbirgt.
Auf jeden Fall. Wir haben äh in unserer Galaxie ähm viele Gammerstrammungsquellen.
Und viele davon sind äh konstant. Und wir reden hier von ähm Überresten von äh Supernova.
Explosionen. Wir reden von sogenannten, was auch was mit äh Supernow Explosion zu tun haben. Wir reden von Pulsaren.
Zwar keine konstante Strahlung aus äh liefern, aber eine Gammastrahlung die ganze Zeit kommt,
ausstrahlen. Äh wir reden von äh sogenannten Gamerienerys. Das sind äh zwei Objekte, die sich umkreisen und äh,
da wird auch Kammerstrahlung gemacht. Wir reden auch hier von galaktischen Zentrum selber,
Strahlung aussendet,
Also es gibt genug Fans äh mit äh dessen Sessivität von Instrumenten, die wir jetzt haben reden wir bereits von 100 oder mehr Quellen in unserer Galaxidy, Kammerstrahlung äh.
Und wo es schon sinnvoll wäre, auch über einen längeren Zeitraum zu beobachten, einfach um ein genaueres Bild davon zu bekommen, was dort eigentlich in diesem Energiebereich stattfindet.
Ja, es ist äh sind mehrere Aspekte, die interessant sind äh wenn wenn das Instruktivität von dem Instrument sich verbessert. Auf einer Seite ist diese räumliche Auflösung.
Reden von ähm.
Auflösung das heißt mit oder die Auflösung ist vielleicht ähm zehn Bogenminuten.
Das heißt wenn ein Objekt kleiner als zehn Bogenminuten ist ähm ist es für uns ein Block. Das ist äh.
Ja es ist ein ein Punkt. Wir wir reden vom Punkt,
bis zehnmal besser in bestimmte Energiebereichen. Das ist schon,
eine Bogenminute. Es ist natürlich nicht zu vergleichen mit Radioteleskopen oder Röntgen Teleskopen, aber trotzdem für uns ist das schon wichtig. Es ist eine eigene Quelle,
sind's mehrere Quellen. Wie wie sehen nur ein Blog? Mit dieser Technik sind es vielleicht mehrere Quellen.
Oder ist es eine Quelle mit der Struktur? Er ist vielleicht auch ähm Struktur nicht nur räumlich, sondern äh viktoskropisch, vielleicht ein Teil von von äh,
von diesem Signal hat ein anderes Energiespektrum anderer,
Bereich. Also es ist sehr viel was wir über die räumliche Auflösung.
Ähm äh lernen können. Das andere ist dieses piktoskopische Auflösung, das heißt äh pro Energiebereich, wie wie gut wir sind. Äh zur Zeit sind wir vielleicht bei fünfzehn, zwanzig Prozent ähm.
Energieauflösung, das heißt äh,
sage ich mal dreihundert GEV, Signal messen, dann ist es äh dreihundert plus minus fünfzehn Prozent. Von da hängt eine Struktur in diesem Energiespektrum versteckt,
die vielleicht nur sehr sehr sehr dünn ist.
Sehr spitz, die würden wir gar nicht sehen, weil es einfach alles alles verwaschen.
Wischt das. Mhm.
Ähm mit äh CTA Teleskopen werden wir viel bessere Energieauflösung haben. Das heißt, wir werden diesen Energiespektrum viel besser studieren können. Und da ist es uns wichtig,
durch das Energiespektrum oder durch die Form des Energiespektrum können wir viel besser unterscheiden, ob,
die Quelle einer elektronischer ist, das heißt diese Elektronen eher beschleunigt.
Und dadurch äh ist die Gammastrahlung entstanden, die wir registrieren oder ist eine Quelle von der kosmischen Strahlung. Das heißt, es sind eher hochenergetische Proton.
Ursprung der Gammerstrahlung, die wir beobachten.
Das ist natürlich ein gutes Argument für.
Diesen nächsten Schritt zu gehen, ne? Also wirklich hin äh ein Observatorium äh anzubieten, was es ja so in dem Sinne derzeit nicht gibt, wenn ich das richtig verstehe. Es gibt halt das äh Familot äh und es gibt äh das LST, die Magic et cetera. All das, was bisher da war
technologische äh Experimente
hat man sich halt einfach mit dem Teleskop vor allem erstmal um die Detektion als solche bemüht. Die zu verbessern, äh die Qualität besser hinzubekommen, zu schauen, was sind eigentlich die Parameter, die man jetzt hier noch äh
verbessern muss, um überhaupt ein Bild wahrsten Sinne des Wortes zu bekommen.
Und diese Entwicklung ist jetzt an dem Punkt angelangt, wo man sagt, okay, wir wissen jetzt, wie das funktioniert. Wir wissen, was wir bauen müssen,
wissen auch, was wir erreichen können, wenn wir das und das bauen,
die beste Methode, das zu machen, ist solche Race aufzubauen, also mehrere Teleskope auf möglichst dichten Raum irgendwo hinzustellen, damit die eben
möglichst viel und dann eben auch damit die Richtung der Gammerstrahlung messen können und in dem Moment, wo man sagt, okay, jetzt äh
funktioniert das alles. Jetzt überlassen wir es quasi der Wissenschaft, den Wissenschaftlern weltweit. Hier selber auf Ideen zu kommen, was man sich denn jetzt genau,
anschaut, weil bisher war das sozusagen, ja, wir brauchen mal eine Quelle, wir müssen hier irgendwie testen, dass es funktioniert und jetzt wissen wir, dass es funktioniert. Jetzt wollen wir sozusagen hier
wie wir das jetzt hier auch in den letzten Podcasts äh besprochen haben, zum Beispiel Grantioskopion bei den optischen Teleskopen ist es ja der Normalfall. Wissenschaftler reichen einfach Beobachtungsanträge ein, die werden ausgewählt, die werden durchgeführt, die Daten werden zurück überliefert. Das fehlt sozusagen derzeit noch für diese äh Bodengestützte Gamma-Strahlen,
Beobachtung, aber das ist jetzt im Prinzip genau der Prozess, der eingeleitet wurde.
Wer äh finanziert denn dieses CTA-Geschichte und was ist dann also sind jetzt genau
diese zwei Standorte erstmal einmal im Norden und einmal im Süden, jeweils vier Teleskope,
drei, also hier dann vier La Palma und im Süden ist dann in Chile kommen dann mehr zum Einsatz.
Ja mehr genau weil vom Süden,
Kann man besser äh das galaktische Zentrum und ähm unsere eigene Galaxie beobachten. Da vermutet man eher die sogenannten Pepatronen zu finden. Das sind ja,
Quellen, die zu den höchsten Energien Protonen äh beschleunigen, die die kosmische Strahlung rausmachen. Äh das kann man wahrscheinlich besser auch vom vom Süden aus sehen.
Da werden drei Teleskoptype gebaut, alle drei, die vier Lifestyle Teleskope,
bis 25 Mietpreisteleskope und bis 70 Smalls heißt Teleskop, also es wird wirklich so eine Fläche von,
ähm zehn Quadratkilometer äh mit Teleskopen zugepflastert. Äh in dem Zentrum von dem Süden werden die vier LSTs,
stehen und dann 25 MSDs irgendwie drumherum und dann viel größere Fläche mit den kleinen so können wir die Energien von,
wir reden hier von 20 Giga-Elektronenvolt, das ist so unsere Energieschwelle, von denen wir messen können,
bis über 300 TV.
Terra-Elektron Volt Pro ähm Gamerstrahlung, das heißt mit so einem äh dadurch, dass wir drei unterschiedliche Teleskopgrößen verwenden, können wir,
Mehr als drei Größenordnungen in der Energie äh abdecken ohne Energie von diese Gammerstrahlung ist ja,
Potenzgesetz äh abfallend mit wahrscheinlich so minus zwei Komma acht äh,
Es ist nicht so wichtig. Äh wichtig ist, dass es mit einem Teleskopentypen nicht möglich so einen großen Energiebereich abzudecken zur Zeit,
Magic oder Hass oder wäre das, die können so in großen Bereich mit einem Teleskopypen nicht abdecken, ohne,
drei unterschiedliche Teleskoptypen,
und äh hier im Norden wird natürlich auch Teil der Milchstraße ist zu sehen, aber äh man hat entschieden, hier keine Teleskope zu bauen.
Das soll dann eher im Süden sein. Hier werden vier LST sein, das eine steht ja schon da und 3 kommen noch dazu. Und das nun dann bis 15 mit Teleskope werden. Äh werden dazu kommen. Nur wer es finanziert, ist natürlich äh teuer,
Man hat sich zusammengesetzt.
Großen Spieler in einem Feld, weil wir sind ungefähr tausend Leute, die in einem Bereich arbeiten.
Man hat vor wahrscheinlich mittlerweile 15 Jahren ähm das Programm angefangen und geguckt nach den Finanzierungsmöglichkeiten.
Und dann hat man ähm sogenannten FB Seven Gelder bekommen, um so eine Infrastruktur auf die Beine zu kommen. Das ist das ist schon ein,
was sehr ähm Europa zentriert ist. Die die Hauptfinanzierung,
ist von Europa und in zur Zeit versucht man ein Erik ähm zustande zu bringen. Eric ist äh European Research in.
Das ist ein ein ein größeres Unterfangen, wo es darum geht, äh,
Unter welcher Flagge diese dann äh sein wird und äh Europa bietet mit diesen Eriks,
ein äh ein legales Konstrukt äh was man was man äh dafür verwenden kann. Da müssen aber wirklich Parlamente von europäischen Ländern,
nicht von allen, aber die die beteiligt sind dem dem zustimmen. Also es ist relativ.
Langwieriges Prozess. Auf der anderen Sache erwarten natürlich die Ministerien, wenn sie so ein Erik äh auf die Beine bringen, dass der European Commission dem auch zustimmt,
ein ah ein offenes Subserratorium ist und nicht nur irgendwelchen 1tausend äh Enthusiasten zur Verfügung steht, die ihre Ideen dann austesten und publizieren, sondern das ist.
Den ganzen europäischen oder äh internationalen äh Gemeinschaft so zur Verfügung stehen.
Und wo wird's dann genau sein, das südliche ZTA?
Paranal in Chile, es ist ähm äh im Prinzip eh so Gelände, das heißt auch als Partner eingestiegen, das Projekt.
Dann äh uns helfen das Servatorium im Süden ähm zu bauen und und zu betreiben.
Parallel ist ja jetzt schon ein riesiger Standort für äh verschiedene Teleskope und dann kommt das sozusagen noch mit dazu.
Ja, es ist eine eine Fläche, die nichts hat.
Aber es ist nicht weit von äh von der Infrastruktur, die äh ESO bereits dort hat und äh das das hilft natürlich durch die ganzen Kontakte, durch die ganze ja Geschichte, die so äh Tortenparanal hat,
so eine Psychatorium bauen zu können.
Wann soll das fertig sein?
Ja am besten gestern.
Dir geht ja.
Aber nun ja sind wir im Prozess äh Erik ähm offiziell zu beantragen und dann dann muss Kommission,
grüner Licht geben und dann irgendwann fließen die Gelder und die Konstruktionsphase soll 5 Jahre betragen.
Wir hoffen, dass wir vielleicht äh äh in ein, zwei Jahren mit dieser Konstruktionsphase beginnen können und dann wird fünf Jahre lang gebaut.
La Palma bauen wir das ähm.
Ähm bisschen schneller, weil wir auch ohne Erik die Möglichkeit äh gefunden haben, das zu finanzieren.
Sehr starker Beitrag kommt auch aus Japan. Ich bin auch von der Universität von Tokio hier umgerechnet 20 Millionen Euro wurden bereits in das Projekt investiert.
Dass vor allem in die LST und äh Spanien hat ähnlich großen Beitrag geliefert. Äh,
sogenannten Federgelder. Das sind ähm europäische Gelder für die Infrastruktur, wann die für Spanien sind, dann können die nur in Spanien verwendet werden.
Haben haben wir eine Möglichkeit gefunden, das für ähm Wissenschaft äh zu verwenden.
So ist es vor allem durch die Anstrengung aus Japan, Spanien, Deutschland, Italien und Frankreich.
Gelungen die Finanzierung für die vier LSDs zu sichern. Das eine steht schon da und die drei weiteren müssen in paar Monaten eher deren Baubeginn haben, so dass wir in drei Jahren fertig sein.
Wollen.
Hier an diesem Standort.
Hier in in auf La Palma, genau, als Teil von CTA.
Und im Süden ist noch total offen, wann das stattfinden wird.
Da ist es noch äh offen, genau.
Okay, aber man weiß schon, äh wo es stehen äh wird. Ist ja auch ein guter äh Gesellschaft. Hier ist mit dem Teleskopio Kanaias ist das größte optische Teleskop, das wird ja dann demnächst abgelöst so. Das steht aber dann halt auch in Paranal mit dem ELT, von daher äh ändert sich nicht viel.
Man steht immer schön nah beieinander. Ja bemerkenswert. Also es wäre dann wirklich eine Fläche, was hast du gesagt? Was ist die Gesamtfläche, die jetzt in einem
maximalen theoretisch maximalen Ausbau angestrebt werden soll. Im Süden.
Im Süden geht es bis zu 10 Quadratkilometern, wenn wir, wenn wir alle Gelder zusammenkriegen, die wir haben wollen, dann ja.
Geht's rund.
Genau hier ungefähr bisschen unter einem Quadratkilometer.
Jetzt ähm würde mich nochmal interessieren, wieso der Prozess dann abläuft, wenn man so ein Observatorium das muss äh schaut halt einfach in einer extrem hohen Zeitauflösung.
Quasi die ganze Zeit einfach in die Atmosphäre.
Ja man guckt dann aber man schaut schon in eine bestimmte Richtung. Man wählt eine bestimmte Quelle welche Quelle das ist. Das ist ein Prozess. Da muss man,
gibt's unterschiedliche Wege, Quellen zu bestimmen, die wir beobachten wollen,
wir nehmen zum Beispiel ein Krebsnebel, Krebsnebel ist ein Standardkerze in unserem Bereich, sie ist auch nicht ganzes Jahr lang zu sehen, aber sagen wir mal.
Kerze, das heißt, man man weiß, es ist mehr oder weniger eine konstante Gamerstrahlung an der Stelle, an der man auch alles andere ausrichten kann.
Genau.
Wenn man da hinguckt, sollte man genau das sehen, sonst ist irgendwas kaputt.
Genau, weil man muss dieses Instrument auch irgendwie eichen können, äh gerät dem Zerren, werden durch bestimmte ja äh künstliche Kalibrationsquellen geeicht.
Diese Möglichkeit haben wir nicht. Wir brauchen keinen Beschleuniger im Himmel, irgendein ähm Super über Rest, was uns äh konstanten Fluss von der Gammerstrahlung liefert, was wir auch in anderen mit anderen Instrumenten sehen können.
Und dadurch wird es äh wird es gereicht. Also das wir gucken jetzt in die Richtung von einem Krebsnebel, natürlich die Erde dreht sich, das heißt Krebsnebel,
nicht ganze Zeit äh und ähm perfekten Bedingungen zu sehen und äh wir haben unser,
Triggersystem, das heißt ähm wenn einer Kamera von einem Teleskop.
Ein äh Signal gemessen zu haben,
drückt das Teleskop selber aufn Aufnahmeknopf und sagt, okay, diese 30 Nanosekunde, diese 40 Nanosekunden nehmen wir jetzt auf.
Da ist was passiert und dann ist vielleicht eine Todzeit vor ein paar Mikrosekunde, da kann man nichts machen und dann sind wir wieder in diesem,
Abwartungsmodus, ob da was passiert. Wir reden jetzt von den einzelnen Bildern, auch wenn der äh Fluss von der von der Garma-Strahlung, von dieser Quelle konstant ist
trotzdem ein Prozess, was was hier stattfinden, die Ereignisse kommen zufällig zustande und wenn äh die Kamera meint wieder irgendwas äh messen zu können,
oder was was interessantes gesehen zu haben, dann äh wird die Information wieder ausgelesen.
So bei diesen großen Teleskopen von LST sind wir jetzt bei acht Kilohertz ungefähr. Die meisten, das heißt 8000 Ereignisse pro Sekunde werden aufgenommen und dann analysiert.
8000 Ereignisse pro Sekunde, ob's jetzt Richtung Krebsnebel oder woanders. Die meisten davon äh sind ja haben gar nicht Gamma, Strahlungsursprung, sondern sind aus von diese kosmische Strahlung,
die sind einfach viel viel mehr da. Für uns ist es aber Untergrund. Den müssen wir dann in Analyseschritt,
sagen, nee, das war, das war doch ein Protonschauer, interessiert uns nicht, uns interessieren kann man Schauer und diese kommen dann je nach ähm Energie, vielleicht äh,
Ja, 20, 30 pro Minute oder oder sogar bis 60, also einmal, einer mal pro Sekunde kommt so ein.
Ähm Ereignis zustande, was von den Kammerstrahlungen.
Verwirrt, also 8tausend mal pro Sekunde, äh aber wir beobachten.
Genau.
Wir beobachten doch jetzt im Nanosekundenbereich, das muss man auch sehr viel feiner auflösen.
Richtig, weil man äh nicht ganze Zeit diese Information, die man Mist aufnimmt, sondern man äh man ist in Standby, man ähm wir reden hier von einem Ringbuffer. Die Information,
Foto Multiplayern registriert wird. Sie wird,
da sind elektrische Signale äh die kommen ganze Zeit und die kommen in einen in einen Ring Buffer, zeitlichen Ringbuffer rein,
Dieses Ringwaffe wird irgendwann überschrieben. Das heißt, die Firma Sufer wenn's nicht ausgelesen wird, dann wird's einfach überschrieben.
Okay, also es geht nicht wirklich was verloren, sondern nur man guckt nur 8tausendmal pro Sekunde nach, war da jetzt was? Und wenn ja, dann fangen.
Aber nicht zufällig, sondern äh wir haben ein Triggersystem in in diesem äh äh in in dieser hochintelligenten Kameras.
Mehrere Photomoji ein Signal höher als irgendwas sehen dann sagen wir mal.
Also erstmal kommen Signale in diesen Trinkwasser und bleiben da paar Mikrosekunden drin,
Triggersystem von der selben Kamera sagt, oh da war was Spannendes dann äh hören wir auf äh das Signal zu sampeln.
Und lesen aus dem Bereich, wo was stattgefunden hat und da schreiben wir dann aufm,
im Datenzentrum rein und dann fangen wir wieder an äh zu sampeln, zu gucken, ob da was passiert. Und dieser Prozess, 800 pro Sekunde findet das statt.
Aber nicht ähm periodisch, sondern zufällig.
Und wenn man jetzt ein Ereignis detektiert hat, wenn man weiß, okay, da war jetzt ein Blitz, da war dieser Blitz. Wie viel Daten erzeugt die Aufnahme dieses einen Events? Ungefähr.
Ja wir reden von mehreren Kilobyte ähm ja mir fehlt jetzt genaue Zahl äh.
Beides ja nix.
Ja aber 8tausend es ist erstmal nicht ein Kilo bei sondern so.
Unsere Kamera hat insgesamt Durchlauf von bis 60Gigabit pro Sekunde.
Und wir nutzen ungefähr die Hälfte davon aus. Also wir mit den Daten, die wir auslesen.
Erzeugen wir ungefähr 30 Gigabit pro Sekunde.
Also ein Rohmaterial.
Und das äh wir haben unsere was von Japan finanziert wurde. Das hat dann äh Speicherplatz von drei Komma vier,
Schon mal schon mal große Zahl und äh nach paar Jahren wir betreiben das jetzt seit zweitausendachtzehn.
Das reicht uns nicht aus. Ähm nächste Woche werden wir ein Upgrade mit 2,3 Peter Bike extra.
Haben wir fast sechs Bettarbeiten insgesamt. Aber irgendwann muss man natürlich diese Daten löschen oder die so reduzieren, dass es dann machbar ist. Also roh und Daten am Ende und das war aussortieren und suchen was, was eigentlich wichtig.
Mal ein bisschen meine Frage. Also auf welchem Level stellt man dann die Daten den Wissenschaftlern äh zur Verfügung? Also wenn ich jetzt angenommen wir haben jetzt diesen Observatoriumsmodus und ich kann jetzt wirklich Beobachtungszeit
beantragen und sagst du hier was weiß ich da ist so ein Pulsar den will ich mir jetzt mal anschauen irgendwie dann wird da,
was weiß ich, wie lange da drauf geschaut wird, vielleicht
Tag oder so, das wäre wahrscheinlich schon sehr viel, ne? Ich weiß nicht. Na ja, äh sagen wir mal, ich habe jetzt so einen Tag und äh der wirft dann, keine Ahnung, paar hundert äh Ereignisse auf, dann bekomme ich ja nicht den rohen Datenstrom, der
der Kamera, sondern es muss ja in irgendeiner Form eine eine Reduktion aufs wesentliche äh statt.
Ganz genau. Ja natürlich, also wir reden hier von dreißig ähGigabit pro Sekunde für eine bestimmte Kamera. Jetzt haben wir eine Ray von den Teleskopen, also natürlich der End-User, derjenige, der die Daten,
beantragt hatte, würde nie zusehen.
Interessiert dich eigentlich auch nicht, ne.
Das auch nicht. Genau, also die Daten werden reduziert und wir reden dann am Ende von.
Äh das heißt Energiespektrum zweit aufgelöstes Energiespektrum äh Lichtkurven, Energiespektren.
Uns. Das ist das, was der End-User dann äh am Ende bekommen wird.
Das ist ein sehr überschaubar.
Genau, das ist dann nicht anders als ähm ein optisches Teleskop oder irgendeinem Teleskop. Und da und dadurch erreichen wir auch viel größere Community als nur diese tausend Leute.
Ähm solche bauen und betreiben kann.
So, jetzt haben wir's eigentlich glaube ich ganz gut äh zusammengefasst schon äh alles. Was ist denn so deine deine Erwartung oder deine Hoffnung, was diese
Art der Beobachtung zukünftig an wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen liefern könnte. Gibt es irgendetwas, was sich
zeichnet, wo das besonders interessant ist oder siehst du mehr äh die Aufgabe so in dieser als als Teil in der Multi-Messenger-Astronomie, also was was könnte so die
die Perspektive sein für äh das vollständige in Betrieb genommene CTA.
Ich persönlich finde, dass,
die Stärke von CTA, die Vielseitigkeit ist, das ist nicht eine bestimmte Objektklasse, die die spannt ist, sondern irgendwie in Gesamtheit.
Von äh von der Reichweite von von dem von dem CTA,
vor der kosmischen Strahlung geredet und von den Objekten, die vielleicht in Frage kommen, äh die Ursprung von äh der kosmischen Strahlung zu sein. Aber es ist ja nur ein Aspekt von ähm,
von Objekten oder von den äh Studien, die wir machen können. Äh unter anderem.
Studieren war fundamentale Physik. Wir suchen zum Beispiel nach der dunklen Materie,
Wir wissen, dass Universum einlegen. Wir sehen, sagen wir, 30 Prozent der Materie, die leuchtet, okay. Aber wo ist äh wo sind die 70 Prozent, die das ganze Universum äh.
Zusammenhält, ja.
Zusammenhält und da eine Klasse von den Modellen sagt uns, dass ähm diese.
Dunkle Materie im Fallchen könnte sie eigentlich hillieren, das heißt miteinander stoßen.
Dass da Gaumastrahlung entsteht und diese Gaumausstrahlung können wir messen, ist genau in dem Bereich, wo wo wir messen. Das heißt, wenn wir,
Gaumausstrahlungssignale aus der Richtung kommen, wo keine ursprüngliche oder herkömmliche zu erwarten ist. Es wäre schon.
Wenn es denn Teilchen sind, also das weiß man ja nicht.
Ja gut äh irgendwas ist ja da, irgendwas äh macht ja Gravitation, irgendwas hält ja die Welt zusammen,
ein Feld von irgendwelchen Teilchen sein, ne? Nur was genau diese Teilchen sind, wissen wir nicht. Und wie sie miteinander reagieren, wissen wir auch nicht. Anscheinend reagieren sie nicht so sehr miteinander, deswegen haben wir es bis jetzt noch nicht gefunden.
Aber ansonsten ja was Eigenschaften haben, wir wissen nur welche,
wie sie elektromagnetisch miteinander umgehen, das wissen wir natürlich nicht,
Des Weiteren können wir Gesetze der der Standardphysik testen, weil wir wirklich in einem extremen Universum, mit den extremen Energien arbeiten.
Ein Beispiel ist äh Lorenz Invariance. Äh wir gehen davon aus, dass ähm.
Egal mit welcher Energie, im Vakuum, mit derselben Geschwindigkeiten ausbreiten.
Es kann aber sein, dass die Lorenzon Variance irgendwo gebrochen ist und äh das wäre dann bei den höchsten Energien sichtbar. Das heißt, wenn wir einen Ausbruch.
In Garmisch-Strahlung haben, dass die höchsten Energien dann schneller zu uns kommen oder langsamer als als niedrige Energien und das wäre, das wäre auch eine Art Revolution des Standardmodells in Physik.
Studieren. Bis jetzt haben wir also ist noch nichts publiziert worden, dass wir es gefunden haben, sonst sonst. Äh hättest du wahrscheinlich gelesen.
Aber sind solche äh natürlich solche Erwartungen sind, die die spannendsten, dass man etwas entdeckt,
was uns noch gar nicht gibt. Studien von bekannten Objekten ist eine Sache, aber ähm Entdeckung von ähm.
Unbekannten.
Ist natürlich das das Spannende von von CTA, weil wir mir dieses Sensivität wir denken, das ist ja schon so eine Art Bergprinzip mit den Teleskopen wie Magic Veritas oder Hess, haben wir jetzt das etabliert. Wir haben,
irgendwelche 300 Quellen in in diesem Energiebereich aber in dem Optischen haben wir Millionen von Quellen,
haben wir auch Millionen von Quellen äh in Kammerstrahlungsbereich oder zehntausend, hunderttausend,
Das ist so ein so so ein Eisberg, wo wir mit der besseren Empfindlichkeit von von da reingehen können und da mal sehen, was wir dann.
Genau an demselben Punkt wie die Gravitationswellen Astronomie noch vor kurzem war, dass man wusste so okay,
Hatte bisher immer Recht. Wird schon was da sein, aber man wusste nicht,
Jetzt irgendwie ein Ereignis alle zehn Jahre oder kriegen wir die Tür nicht zu und jetzt weiß man, okay alles klar, irgendwo dazwischen
äh so, dass es auch sinnvoll ist. Das heißt, man kann noch relativ viel beobachten. Es wird am laufenden Meter eine neue äh gemacht. Ähnliches könnte sich auch hier einstellen, dass man einfach,
bestimmte Bereiche beobachtet und feststellt so oh da ist ja ganz schön was los da können wir jetzt aber auch richtig etwas draus
ableiten. Jetzt gewinnen wir Informationen und vielleicht sind's Informationen
die äh ja die bisherigen physikalischen Gesetze einfach nur bestätigen. Ist ja auch was schönes oder vielleicht so eine komplett neue Tür aufmachen, die dann halt äh Einblicke bieten in
was es auch immer sein mag, tunkte Energie, dunkle Materie äh gibt ja genug zur Auswahl an äh Mysterien ähm
derzeit äh man weiß ja eigentlich nix.
Werden sehen.
Ja, wir werden's sehen. Daniel, vielen, vielen Dank für die äh Erläuterungen der Curringkovstrahlung und des Prinzips der.
Direktoren und natürlich auch das gesamte Projekt des CTA. Ich wünsche euch da viel Erfolg damit. Das klingt auf jeden Fall sehr.
Danke fürs Mitmachen. Und ich sage auch vielen Dank fürs Zuhören hier bei Raumzeit. Ihr wisst, bald geht's wieder weiter.